[Music]
foreign
[Music]
basically a single unit of information
in a quantum computer
it's not maybe not the most Whimsical of
names but it's it's literally if you
take the cue from Quantum and add it to
bit that's or I guess the qu from
Quantum and add it to bit you get Cupid
right
um we can predict what a single qubit
will do uh by keeping so like if we want
to actually simulate a quantum computer
you know you're if you've taken a
quantum mechanics class or something
like that you'll know that we we can
simulate all of that with basically
linear algebra so
um and that's uh you know if you're not
super familiar with linear algebra or
it's it's been a while it's been a hot
minute uh we do have a pretty good
appendix covering what you need to know
in the book uh if you if you need it but
basically a qubit can be represented as
a vector column Vector of two complex
numbers so like a regular bit in a
classical computer is just a one or a
zero
a qubit or a singular unit of quantum
information can be represented by this
Vector of two complex numbers so here
I'm actually importing Q-tip and using
Q-tip to actually uh kind of represent a
Quantum in this case uh their Quantum
object class but it represents a single
qubit we stay say that our qubit has
this state basically by manipulating
these vectors that represent the state
and uh matrices which represent the
operations that you're going to do on
them whether it's like the H operation
that we saw before or ones that operate
on multiple qubits at once
you basically just multiply them all
together and then you get a vector at
the end and then that basically
represents uh you can use
um
like born's rule or you can use your
software tools to figure out what
problem what you would measure with what
probability at the end we've got a qubit
what are like what can we actually do
with a qubit the sample we've looked at
so far kind of gives us a pretty good
outline of that right basically we can
prepare qubit so that's kind of like the
using statement we can do things with
the qubit we can do operations so that's
like applying H operation we'll see a
few more examples of different types of
operations we can do and then you can
measure a qubit so what's interesting
though is when you measure a qubit you
don't like get that full Vector of two
complex like two complex numbers back
out that's a way to represent the
information it has but that is not
accessible to us what we get out if we
measure a qubit is a classical one or a
zero so it's kind of interesting if I
measure a Quantum register
it gives me the same type of information
as if I measure a classical register
and so a lot of the trick and art and
Nuance of Designing Quantum programs and
Quantum algorithms is trying to figure
out how to get this the state's uh uh
that represent your qubits
kind of arranged in such a way that when
you measure it and kind of collapse it
into this classical information that you
either have a high probability of
measuring what you want or Quantum
algorithms can actually be deterministic
and we'll see an example of one here in
a minute but so it's not strictly
speaking a determine or a probabilistic
sort of device now that we've kind of
seen like this is our sample we have
each of those three kind of covered
there preparation operation and
measurement we've seen one way that we
can kind of interact with python and Q
sharp which was again python saw like we
use the Q sharp python package it
managed to kind of compile git and
compile Q sharp code in the same
directory and add it to kind of our our
python instance I guess so another way
we can do this is we can actually
directly provide text or or strings for
uh the Q sharp package for python to
compile directly in our python code so
here you can see I'm using this python
function called compile
and basically providing this big block
quote of what is valid Q sharp code and
so I'm actually just going to ask it to
kind of compile that for me and now just
like as if it had kind of uploaded this
from from a local file I can run it
and I can actually
it's exactly the same
so it kind of depends on on which way
you like uh doing things I kind of like
writing the Q sharp code in my editor
where I have intellisense and syntax
highlighting and stuff like that and
then can like importing it into the
python what we actually defined in this
code snippet we opened one of the
library name spaces actually so called
Diagnostics
and we Define an operation called
prepare qubit and what's happened is
basically uh we've asked for a qubit
from the runtime
and we're going to use a an function
from the Diagnostics package called dump
machine which basically says okay
this Quantum Code is this Quantum
program is going to run on a specific
Target machine wherever like when we get
to this point in the program I'm going
to ask the target machine
please can we print out everything you
know about yourself
um so if this is a simulator the
simulator is keeping track of those
vectors and matrices and stuff like that
all the linear algebra stuff and so it's
going to print out
all the linear algebra stuff and so what
you can see here is basically
a nice kind of formatted version of of
the
values in that Vector so basically the
vector would be 1 0. so there's there's
no imaginary component here and the bars
so this stands for measurement
probability so if you were to measure
this qubit
um we would 100 of the time measure a
zero
um and that makes sense this is a good
sanity check because anytime we ask for
a qubit from the runtime uh it should be
provided to us in this state so it
should be provided in the zero state
it's kind of a good it's a kind of a
built-in promise and or assumption that
we have with the compiler in runtime
that
when we ask for a qubit it'll be in the
zero State that's the same state we saw
earlier that we actually had written in
Q-tip this dump machine I kind of it
kind of feels a lot like printf
debugging which is I mean we've all done
it it's a very helpful technique
um but uh so dump machine kind of really
can help us inspect and see what's going
on with the different operations and
things in our program
so again I'm going to import from our
namespace in the separate file in our in
our directory I'm going to import qrng
with Diagnostics so basically what I've
done now is I've thrown in a couple
different of these dump machines
throughout the program so uh when we
first asked for a qubit great it's in
the zero state
that's exactly what we wanted after we
apply this H operation though so the
hadamard operation what you can see is
it basically shifts uh so that both the
zero and one uh kind of state or
measured uh State vectors here have the
same amplitude so what that mean is our
column Vector is now basically
technically it's 1 over square root of
two one over square root of two because
you have to square these amplitudes to
get to a measurement probability
but you can also see that those are
those are equal basically you can think
of a hadamard operation as something
that can put a qubit in superposition
like I noted before dump machine only
can show you the information that the
target machine has about itself if we
were able to run this on Hardware which
uh actually technically I could right
now but everything is in preview and I'm
not sure the the NDA allows for that
dump machine can only show you what the
actual uh
Target machine knows about your system
if it's Hardware it could it might
report things like temperatures or other
sorts of like Hardware parameters but
can't actually tell you what the vector
that represents your state is because it
doesn't know that so this is all good
but we've mostly been working with a
single qubit so far right
that may not be the most interesting so
what if we want more cubits what do we
do then when you do operations with
multiple qubits that's basically when
you have the possibility for
entanglement so kind of the two core
features or or phenomena that we can
leverage on our Quantum devices that are
uniquely Quantum our superposition and
entanglement so using Q sharp with
python we can also explore what
entanglement looks like so again I'm
going to import an operation here called
entangled qubits
and I'm going to kind of
so this is again code that's defined in
that separate file now if we're
allocating two qubits there's basically
if we were to measure both qubits
there's four possible outcomes right so
each qubit can be a one or zero that's
two to the two so that's four
and and how you can read this is
basically each of these lines is one
possible measurement outcome so this
would be both of them measuring to zero
this would be the first one measuring to
one or is there first one measuring to
zero second one measuring to one
and so uh we see when we first asked for
the qubits from uh the runtime uh they
both show up in the zero State and
that's why this is 100 we know we are in
the zero zero state after we do
entanglement though
what you can see is now our amplitude or
our measurement probability is split
between both zero zero and one one and
again it's kind of this even kind of
like we saw with the hat with the H
operation it's a superposition but it's
what's interesting is there's no chance
we measure a zero one or a one zero what
that tells us though is uh there is
never a way that we will measure a zero
on one qubit and a one on the other so
what that we can measure one of our
qubits and know for sure what the other
qubit actually is because there is no
probability that it could be the
opposite of what we just measured if
that makes sense we've excluded the
middle and you can do this with like one
zero zero one like this is a particular
just one particular instance of
entanglement it doesn't always have to
be exactly zero zero one one or you know
however many qubits you have no matter
how many times uh we kind of run this
entanglement generation protocol when we
go to measure our qubits we're only like
I said only going to measure uh in this
case both ones or both zeros
now this is a really unique resource
that we can leverage
um to actually work with our our qrng
that we had from the beginning and
actually use it to share this Randomness
from uh like between two people and that
actually uh that in that protocol or
kind of area is called Quantum key
distribution and it's an interesting way
we can take existing Quantum technology
uh and actually upgrade our Quant our
crypto cryptography like kind of
landscape so that it's not Quantum being
the bad guy Quantum is helping to build
better Solutions I want to very quickly
kind of show you one more
um
Quantum algorithm to kind of show you
like we looked at some very basic like
Hello World sorts of things we looked at
how we can make superposition and
entanglement
and now I kind of want to show you an
example where we put all that together
and actually write an algorithm that
allows us to solve
a problem the problem here is still kind
of uh constructed we call it like a toy
toy problem or something like that but
it actually represents a very useful
like subroutine that you can use in
larger
um
algorithms which are quite frequently
um
like the most useful Quantum algorithms
that we know of right now are usually uh
what we call hybrid algorithms so they
have a bunch of classical like steps and
processing and then there's you know
some subroutine some Quantum subroutine
that kind of iterates with the classical
algorithm and that's how you get
um how you get your answer I'm going to
set up the toy problem for you this is
this is going to take some story time
and just so you know these characters
Merlin nemune
Arthur I'll make a lot of appearances in
the book as well because we're we
thought we're like well we're we're
trying we have to come up with some kind
of toy problems we might as well have
some fun characters so we have a very
Camelot theme uh which actually comes
from there are a lot of quantum theory
papers that kind of involve Merlin uh
and and King Arthur and stuff like that
imagine Camelot uh and we have uh the
great wizard Merlin and uh the Lady of
the Lake namune so both of these are you
know very very smart uh lived for a long
time sorts of folks uh and they're kind
of trying to decide what to do uh about
the kingdom of catalog and Arthur and
Mordred uh so King arth well spoiler
alert King Arthur
um and Mordred are currently fighting
for the throne so Mordred I think is
Arthur's half-brother
it doesn't matter
they both want to be king
so namune uh being the lady of the like
and being as you know elegant and aloof
as she is wants to make sure that Merlin
is going to be a good counsel for the
king so Merlin signed up to basically
Mentor whoever the new king is and is
actually going to to pick who he wants
to be the next king
um namune doesn't really care who he
picks though uh she just wants to make
sure he's gonna do his job basically
um so the the kind of question or
problem here is is there a way for an
immune to make sure that Merlin is gonna
do his job
uh but without having to kind of learn
the details about what Merlin's gonna
choose uh in terms of who's gonna make
King and stuff like that and turns out
we can kind of turn this into a game
um games are a great way to kind of like
set up a problem that that make that
it's easy to solve or to make it easier
to see how you might solve it so we call
this game kingmaker namune wants to ask
Merlin a single question uh of the form
basically should a particular Heir be
the king so she could ask like should
Arthur be king or should Mordred be king
and Merlin has to respond with either a
yes or no revealing absolutely nothing
else
so basically given that there are two
possible questions and two possible
answers that Merlin can give to each
question we have kind of this table here
so Merlin can have basically four
strategies if an immune asks hey is
Arthur gonna be king if Merlin actually
picked Arthur he'll say yes if he picked
Mordred he'll say no
um he could actually also
um be lazy or be trying to like just get
an immune to go away and he could say
yes to both questions or no to both
questions so basically uh namune wants
to make sure that one of these first two
cases is true in that
Merlin's gonna actually pick somebody
and not just go uh hang out you know
smoking his pipe with uh with Gandalf or
something like that
um so yeah and and that's basically so
what we want to know is is is
um Merlin using one of the first two
strategies or one of the second two
strategies there
um and we can kind of model this as a
one bit to one bit function
um so basically of the inputs aren't
immune's questions the outputs are
Merlin's responses and we can basically
diagram each of those strategies as as
one of these one bit to one bit
functions you can see we're getting
closer and closer to a mathematical
thing now we can actually kind of arrive
at what is the Deutsche choza algorithm
so this is a Quantum algorithm that if
we are given a a black box Quantum
operation called an oracle
um which takes one bit in a one qubit in
and acts on one target qubit that you
get out
uh we're promised that the Oracle is
either constant or balanced so this
Oracle represents basically Merlin's
strategy
and we want to figure out whether the
Oracle is constant or balanced so the
constant or balance thing basically
refers to
um
is are we in the Merlin's gonna do his
job case or are we in the Merlin is
gonna slack off case and you can see
that here basically a con a balanced
function is going to be one of these
first two
uh because basically all the all the
inputs go to all the outputs and then
the constants are basically all the
inputs mapped to a single output that's
basically what that means the balanced
ones here represent Merlin doing his job
so ideally when we when we try to figure
out what this Oracle
what type of Oracle this is we want it
to be balanced not constant we're
actually going to be able to solve this
in just one query to the black box or
one query to this Oracle now given our
formulation that might not seem like a
a lot of savings because if we're due to
to do this classically
we would just like if you were an immune
I guess you could probably ask Arthur
both questions right and you would then
know for sure which of these four cases
uh or which of the four strategies
Merlin's using but we don't actually
care about knowing what his specific
strategy is right so right now I can
like the quantum algorithm we can use
allows us to go from two queries to one
query
which doesn't sound like super green
however this generalizes to end bit by
nbit functions so if we had n different
questions and end different like
responses that Merlin could give for
each question it would still only take
us one query to find this out basically
we go from an order n scaling to one
which so that that's like the quantum
speed up that we see for this problem if
we want to look at
trying to make it show me more code at
once if we want to look at the kind of
the key operation here that checks if an
oracle is balanced it takes an oracle as
input
um we basically use two qubits uh so we
call them control and Target
we prepare one of them in superposition
and then use some other uh sorts of like
specialized Quantum
um
structures in Q sharp one one example of
this is within apply so it's a common
pattern in Quantum algorithms to
basically do some preparation
do something you know in the middle and
then undo your preparation and so the
within apply block structure makes that
really easy to do because I don't have
to remember to undo everything at the
end you know it's kind of like having
automated memory management
um or at least that's kind of what it
feels like to me I don't have to
manually manage this
Q sharp takes care of it for me that's
kind of the basic just all of this is in
actually chapters
six seven
and eight of the book basically part two
of the book uh you kind of really get
into writing some Quantum algorithms and
stuff like that I can real quick compile
some of this stuff in line and uh
if I want to run so
I have basically stored here
using the zero Oracle so the zero Oracle
meaning
that's where Merlin just says no to all
of all of an immune's questions which
means he's not going to do his job
uh and we want to check to see if that's
balanced so balanced here meaning that's
the good case so
is is the zero Oracle balanced is false
because it doesn't actually match
so I guess longer tournament is yay the
algorithm does what we expect and if we
do this for the one Oracle that should
basically do the same thing they both
will say false because they are both not
balanced oracles
now if we run one is the not Oracle
balanced
um then surprise surprise it is and
that's basically uh you know our one
query to actually find that out there's
a lot more details to this uh we have an
entire chapter dedicated to this I would
strongly encourage you check out a lot
more of the details there's more than I
can talk about here but basically the
long and short of it is we took a
problem that would normally take n
queries to solve and did it in one yeah
we can basically use some of the testing
stuff in Q sharp uh to basically write
tests to make sure that you know each of
those oracles acts as we uh think they
should so we have verified that
camelot's future is safe and uh we and
immune wrote a Quantum algorithm to make
sure of it
so uh yeah and also namune is the Lady
of the Lake she so she basically was uh
the person guarding Excalibur in the
lake you know prior to King Arthur
getting it assuming that Merlin is still
willing to do his job